last night's Best Picture winner some
people are upset that um the best
students scuse me excuse me
oh sorry yeah well sir what are you
doing it's my sister's a huge fan of
yours and she was supposed to be her but
she hurt her neck skiing so I came
instead and I was gonna take a selfie of
me and you to cheer her up
I didn't mean to oh okay well that's
actually that's kind of sweet it's just
I don't it's not cool to sneak one once
she's come up here let's take a selfie
for out who's it Allison yes right
thank you anyway what I was saying was
when Greenville for Best Picture what
what what's going on it's nothing what
is it what is it it's just you're
blinking in the picture you know that
kind of face
we'll just come back up here hurry up
man my camera's not so good on the funk
we just use your the TV cameras yes it's
high-def we can do that okay yeah Billy
do me a favor can you just take it to
camera two right here Thanks oh and
Billy the the stage lights are a bit
harsh could you just bring those down a
little bit things fine is that okay here
we go here we go here we go Ellie I'm
getting a little bit of shine on my
forehead if I get some makeup not as
much as Conan but thank you okay you
right you ready now you ready to go
let's do a hand on a blade I feel a
little underdressed if I could just get
a jacket Billy like 46 long it's great
all right now you're under dress okay
all right maybe a nicer backdrop so with
the backdrop we'll use that on the show
that's the show background of outdoorsy
yeah we motion graphic the lower third
that says you don't like get-well-soon
Allison from your friends at Conan but
that's gonna be hard - okay there we go
good hey I thought maybe we could do a
little recasting let's recast your part
be like we got a better-looking version
of what's your name Jeff Jeff let's get
a better look aquarium deck here
here we go 1 2 3
and get well soon Alison yeah with you
you're a great girl not girlfriend's
sister great sister yeah whatever thanks
a lot you can go back to your seat Jeff
okay just go back to your seat yeah hey
listen sentiment we have an amazing show
we have a great show tonight we have the
stick around with me yeah I just wanted
to make myself feel worse
co-creator star of the amazing HBO
series high-maintenance Ben Sinclair
[Applause]